our uh the david pakman show subreddit
is now
uh it's amazing what's going on over 31
000 of our viewers are now subscribed
for free at davidpakman.com
reddit i want to look at a few posts i
saw this morning user jp dinzie's posted
in response to our segment about
apparently marjorie taylor green the
republican congresswoman
just learning that the holocaust was
really bad
jp dinsey's posts yeah people are just
as or
even dumber than marjorie taylor greene
on the holocaust writing
me and david are both jewish so we
learned pretty extensively about the
holocaust and the reasons it happened
but very few other people really know
what it was or how it happened some
people think all the jews were
just put in gas chambers some think it
was only jews in germany that were
attacked in a recent poll
25 percent of young new yorkers believe
jews caused the holocaust now i looked
that study up it's actually
20 of young new yorkers but that's true
20 percent of young new yorkers believed
that the jews caused or were responsible
for
the holocaust and the point here is that
um jp denzis says
my shock at how uninformed green
was and probably still is about the
holocaust
is actually uh not that rare her her
lack of knowledge about the holocaust
is not that unusual if that's true
that's extraordinarily disturbing
uh i'm not saying that that it's it's
untrue it actually
very well may be true um one of the
things i've learned in doing this show
is if you overestimate the intelligence
of the american people
you are often disappointed and that's
really how we got trump
uh many people said that there's not
enough
stupid people in this country that
they're going to elect trump and then
the republican primary voters chose him
and then
so so did the american people so yeah i
i think
the the big lesson from doing this show
is
do not overestimate the intelligence of
the american people
another post about yet another airline
flight
rerouted this one from or to
san francisco rerouted because of an
argument
over elbow placement on arm rests and
listen elbow placement on armrests is a
conflict
uh you have to figure out do you share
someone gets the front of the arm rest
and someone gets the back or whatever
the airline uh you know it's not
road rage it's air rage it is crazy what
is going on i have a bunch of flights
coming up i am going to do everything i
can and
this is my commitment to you right now
i'm going to do everything i can to
avoid getting involved in any such
incident
um yeah let's see if i succeed and then
lastly
i love this we had a call on monday from
a horrible anti-semitic
military veteran and uh reddit user
baron steuben
posted progressive veterans don't let
people like the one in the voicemail
or the traitors on january 6th give
veterans a bad name
plenty of us are proud progressives who
want to mail help make this country
better for everyone
organizations like common defense and
vote vets embody this goal
and should be in the public eye more i
am very much aware of that we have a lot
of uh progressive veterans in our
audience uh
more veterans voted for joe biden the
democratic candidate
in the last election than have voted for
any democratic candidate in a long time
i don't falsely believe that veterans
are this
uh conservative monolith there are many
conservatives in in the military
just like in law enforcement but there
are plenty of progressive veterans
and appreciate the message of support
you can join the discussion
at davidpakman.com reddit
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com pacman i've been
using privacy for a little over a year
now you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something
online or on the phone instead of
actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information
so this allows you to keep your banking
information secure but also to take
control of your finances
you can create up to 12 of these virtual
credit cards a month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches
and identity theft and it's free and
like i said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman